i got a really good example for you guys
you ready for this one
we have the story from august 19th 2021
oh it is from cnn
from chris saliza ah the great
crystallization republicans
okay republicans keep trying to make
biden's mental capacity and issue oh no
and then that he goes on to mention
people calling him out you know saying
that his mental capacity is an issue and
it's a republican game and blah blah
blah i'm not going to read this right
you know why
because i can just pull up first from a
day later
most voters deemed but an unfit to be
president poll shows okay okay well
that's not
saying mental capacity like chris eliza
was challenging but it does show that
most voters think he's not capable of
being president
now we have this story
less than half of americans say bannon
is mentally stable enough to serve as
president chris
it's not republicans trying to make it
an issue yeah it's people being polled
saying his brain don't work it's an
issue it's an issue it's an issue yeah
i'm i i i'm i'm feeling pretty
black-pilled on this yeah because
earlier today
i'm looking at all this news and i see
this story less than half of americans
say button is meant is is mentally
stable enough to serve as president
and i was like yeah we know that
and then i'm thinking to myself so i did
a segment on this where i was like
not as much about the fact that biden
can't
function properly and everything's
collapsing and the country is basically
on fire and i was just like i know the
border screwed up i know the economy
screwed up i know our foreign policy
screwed up i know the president has no
idea what's going on and i know his
cabinet's in shambles and they're
confused gensake is muttering and
stuttering and stamming and stammering
and circling back and then i'm like what
am i even going to say about this yeah
and then i was like actually
if that's where we're at as a country
we are
seriously screwed
well i i i i'll bleep myself we are
bleeped yeah okay because
we're at a point now where it is
uninteresting to people to hear that the
president of the united states
is viewed as mentally unfit
mentally
not not mentally stable enough
that that we're seeing the catastrophe
and the crisis across the country and
we've normalized to it to the point
where it is not surprising to hear
americans don't see the president as
stable mentally stable i i have a
slightly different theory and i wonder i
was developing this idea while we were
talking about the hunter biden story so
the laptop now is officially correct
everyone agrees the new york post of
course is shocked this is the case
um but i think i wonder if the hunter
biden thing is a segway to being like oh
my gosh biden is incredibly corrupt not
only do most people think he's unfit to
be president like mentally unstable they
also think he's super corrupt maybe we
should just 25th amendment him out of
here so maybe maybe kamala harris's team
made this story get to politico to say
let's just start you know doing the
damage i don't know right
yeah that's that's a great that's a
great theory you mentioned gen saki
today and and and just again
the spinning of lies what we need is we
need like your parents remember when you
would get caught like either drunk or
late or whatever as a kid and you tried
to tell your mom a story and she was
like
no like tell me what the hell actually
happened like she wasn't buying it
ginsaki today when peter ducey asked so
you are asking europeans to show their
coveted passport but if you cross the
border illegally you don't have to show
your coveted passport and she said well
yes unlike the europeans the illegals
are not planning to stay a long time
and that was the end of the question and
no one in the room was the mom to be
like wait wait wait wait wait wait hold
up you think the europeans are staying a
long time and the illegals are temporary
like they're not here for travel
like
what you just said is a complete 180
degree lie they just like oh genseki
said this and they write it down and
they and they tweet it and that's it and
they we need an adult to finally say
time out time out jen that was just a
lie we want to you want to take that
over again we just accept
lies i mean we would need a michael
malus press secretariat yes
yes we would miss his caucus libertarian
dave smith i don't even care if this
whole country becomes communist in 20
years if i can see michael malus's press
secretary for one day
i will die happy that's all i want to
say there's one guy in the diplomatic
press corps when i used to work at the
state department in the bush
administration long long time ago and
he's still there matt lee and he is by
far the senior most foreign policy uh
journalist
and he used to make our lives miserable
because i worked in the press office
and he he was ruthless and he's the only
one but again it doesn't get as much
attention because it's the foreign
policy be but but he will just take him
to ask and say no no no hang on you just
said this
you said this yesterday that doesn't
make any sense like if you ever watch
his exchange he does not buy bs that's
really the difference between an
investigative journalist and a reporter
yeah reporter is going to say you lie to
him and i'm just going to report on the
law or the white house press pool where
they're all just let go gen sec he said
this and they type it down we need more
investigated journalists
but they don't really get invited right
it's like an invite-only thing no it's
it's it's press work it's the white
house reporters they're they're just
there to ask questions and report what's
said they're not investigating but we
definitely need
you know you know we need someone to
challenge it but i'll say this
nobody cares you know why
because when we look at stories about
you know like the cnn republicans are
trying to make it an issue that biden's
not mentally republicans pounce and i'm
like it's i'm not it's not republicans
um it's independent voters
overwhelmingly disapprove of joe biden
yeah but everything you know i love it
when when i did the russell brand
podcast and was talking about civil war
and i just went to town as fast as i
could on all the different points about
like street fighting january uh six all
that stuff
and psychological warfare fifth
generational warfare and the comments
were like tim poole is a leftist you
know he says this about trump timpool is
a right winger he says this about biden
and i'm just like
these people don't seem to realize that
independent voters exist yeah so they
come out and they're like it's just
republicans and i'm like
you know it was funny there was this
research that the researcher who did
this thing on youtube years ago where he
was tracking the political uh
persuasions of youtube recommendations
and he was doing it because of this idea
of the rabbit hole that they kept
pushing and so he had uh i think he
basically had four categories left
center right and exclusively critical of
left
and he initially put people like me and
dave ruben in the category of
exclusively critical of left
and so i talked to him and i pointed out
like
why is that the case when i do express
my opinions that are i think the real
issue was we were taught we were
complaining about democrats
but our opinions were not right-wing
that was the only issue so if i said
something like hey a green new deal that
actually rebuilds infrastructure is a
good thing the democrats are pushing
some weird socialist garbage about
universal college that's not a green new
deal he's like you're just criticizing
the left i'm like i'm literally
supporting a leftist policy but either
the left was in favor of critical race
theory
centrists were like mixed on it and the
right opposed it so if you opposed
critical race theory you were just
called a critical of left
i'm like that that that's how people
even researchers view what's happening
right now and i'm like isn't it perhaps
you're a centrist then or heterodox or
something or politically homeless
no
politics only flows in one direction if
a right-wing dude stands next to a
left-wing dude the left-wing dude is
called right-wing if a right-wing dude
is hanging out with antifa and they're
all waving anti-flags and he's got his
arms around their you know their
shoulders with his thumbs up they will
say they're actually secret right
wingers yeah
yeah when i get into conversations with
this with people my favorite things to
say is okay so you hear about the right
wing a lot the right wing is obviously a
problem in your view right oh yeah
definitely definitely the news is always
reporting it there's a there you know
far right-wing extremists i was just
like so is there a is there a far left
oh no there's not a fart left
they don't they don't they just can't
see it they refuse to see it it's
willful blindness yeah and legislatively
they know that because that's why they
have to like you mentioned the green new
deal with all this leftist
garbage in it
and i also oppose the green new deal um
but they have to sneak that leftist
garbage in it because if it stood on its
own they know they wouldn't have a vote
for it look you mentioned the beginning
of the show you mentioned the
immigration bill why they trying to tag
it into a spending bill because they
know they can't pass an immigration but
the immigration bill they want so they
have to squeeze it into and that's just
what our congress does now we don't
write if we could have a vote on this
water bottle where everyone yay or nay
water bottle congress would work but
instead it's like well we can't do that
because we don't want to i don't want to
go on record about the water bottle
right so we take
everything and throw it on a fourth
house and that's where we are 4 000 page
3.5 trillion dollars we will vote on it
on christmas eve at nine o'clock at
night and that's what we do because all
of these things if they stood on their
own i don't want to get judged on that
so we throw them all in this crap
sandwich and we call it like the for the
children of tomorrow holding hands
across america
and then like if you don't vote for this
chris you hate the troops and they're
like and you hate america and it's like
i just want to vote on the water bottle
but hold on so why doesn't rand paul or
thomas massey just slide stuff in i'll
tell you this when they did the omnibus
spending bill remember that 5 000
something pages 12 million dollars for
pakistani gender studies programs i
don't know about any of you listening
but i don't care from the left or the
right we can all agree that spending 12
million on gender study programs in
america is better than giving it to
pakistan at least you'd create american
jobs actually i don't know if i agree
with that necessarily we don't want
weird but i guess
but why are we giving our money away for
ridiculous things like this more
importantly when i see that i'm like
rand paul yeah if you're listening
can you just write something very simple
saying and we abolish the federal
reserve yeah and just slide it in there
because nobody read it
he knows nobody right everybody votes on
it and they're like yay and then all of
a sudden they're like did we just
abolish the federal reserve
so why doesn't he do that i don't know
because they they i think because they
see the process as an honorable
righteous constitutionally mandated and
this is how we do it so we don't violate
the rules thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you